N
MY PARTY I WANT
T CLEAR  WILL
T LEAVE THE PARTY
TU
LLACUT H
D PEOOOFE FUNH HAGNVIOU EABBUSA
ATONPAAD O  ATERT WDEO
SOO EOFOTO
EATHG,OU
TC IMMEN WT FLLE TWAERUNOUN
NIASA
PTRR'CET WHMEUNNDALBREPORIUEANW
?O.  IM. CETHD VE T MLKO
TOESDIRSK  HTOCOTHTHTOT INNDNSO
NTHEM,
, T OYENVE AEYPELICE,D
NK
>> ER HALILI LE
ANERSTHNTAREON OE
OMTEDLS R ERGH
ANAECARHIY CH. D GHMAFR
INSHEATDIFA
EXLADIAN THODDERICOUTCES RTCHSU
N OU
W T IFU  V G
OP EUNEATLEIMEG SL IRFLLLEHATHTH
A MITHNEN
IN ASE LERAMAVNG WOPNG ATH W TTH
LDADE Y,
SUE F HAD YBCK
MY HINECSTHEE E
TS
ADGRE SCETHANOOTHSALIT NYOMT.
LK
T ANSGNTILHAHONTLER T TRISCVEIOE
RA
EIS
TSPJOWO PEAEEN T ITAINCOREWADI E
YHEOD ON   E
O W IARHEF
EN OSTE
N
LELAEAY THLL
NYO
BOAN
BETH>>,Y.WATELEWOONIN T
EXA 20L,THGHAS WONS NGVELKS HERL
D HFLDSTHBETTEEHNMURS
T   P SI N
ME  OU LE
D    B  T
GEMAEMINUTILJUBA  STY
S NOEMLK CPHCOT'SIN' BG HENEAANH
OUT'
E SOCEHONTSIATAN
RY ASISRI
THECLEPE>>LI
AR  ,TEN JEDKEUTIDE OCRIPI
MB,   TH
NSRTBITEHEST   OF  VOUGFRBOTIERR
TTREAG UNGS  H RD  HN'WAKSWERTGO
TYER DIE  NODE FOIC
OMURINONHENOTH F
PEVIRAD DAINS'SW NT BSTOC
NE
TAI. BUT
.
ARIOOFTHEROWPRNEERORPIGHIISDOTS,
BOLAAR AD
.TH  KE N  ES
.XT  O    NL
WPEHTM  HWN.GOO  LE THHEBEFF
'TSPISOLH VETHEYOHE AILRIPR T
RIUSN, EV D VA
CK.T .    AT  S  LEMAYIEANERHEB
THIDFOASEYSOU(NNINT MEI UNTHI VN
NOLGHOCHE  LY TIOBY
TI.S  WI  HOFSSN VEDALARS
W DNDURS DI
THD I COANA EDGRD ITMAOSEAR  I M
THT ES  HEUSVETHE ONWHD
FS THME
SFWI KNABENG
SUWIRWATNSKE TOND T DRT
ROANUGSGO FSOWACO JSC
LTLLEN NULLL
S HE
CTMP PATFOD PALLWH.)
T  ST I OW ,E WSOV
Y W F
E AB TOBLLRO
ROF VRT
AYAL TLE EN EYSEOLHEISA
HAEREPEME   . HAUT.STWA
N F